hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to let's play The Last
of Us okay we just got some awesome
supplies in here and now we need to move
forward throughout the sewers so that we
can make our way to where we need to go
I'm pretty sure we're full up on all
craftables I've got comics for Ellie
there that she's going to read later on
because she is nagging me about it I
don't know I couldn't find a gay porno
Max for her so I couldn't I couldn't get
anything else so
anyway
I hope these guys aren't leading me into
a trap that would really really suck if
these guys actually were leading me into
a trap but I mean I don't think so
because they seem like cool guys and
there's a kid with them so I would just
guess that it's going to be okay all
right what have we got here oh hello can
we get out this way probably not oh
hello there's no way to reach that it's
stuck it's jammed can't swim that makes
two of us well that means I got to swim
right so
spoel how do we get across hey shut up
I'll handle it all right I figured
there'd be something stuck in the
gears look how strong I am sweet I'm the
best gosh I'm
great try now Henry give it a
shot can you do it are you strong
enough wow good job there
Henry yeah it's working okay actually
that is pretty
impressive okie dokie let's see what's
in here I'll go have a look you keep an
eye out yeah I'll just go off on my own
replace all my human enemies with zombie
enemies which everyone knows is what I
like most in these games that's what I
care about most okay hang on some
through here some supplies yes awesome
I'm being very very diligent about
getting the supplies but then you guys
know about that now I bet now I'm
recording these in batch um I bet you
guys are now like in glowing admiration
of my amazing play playing abilities
right right you're saying wow we never
knew Mark was so Pro oh wait yes we did
okay oh am I going
to I hear
that I hear
that
where's that coming
from I don't like the sound of that
switching out to the other
gun hang on is there something behind
this
door is it
shable nope
oh
okay
so what do I do about that okay there's
two in there I'm actually going to go
back down and see if I can't F them
across before I I face all these guys on
my own I mean I could but clickers scare
me much more than human enemies do so
I'm going to try to be as careful as
possible I guess I'm just going to have
to FY everyone
across Henry can't you
swim maybe you could help me out here
yeah shut up Ellie
get
on Ellie Ellie come
on what was it not good enough for you
right there how about here let's go well
oh there you go that's smart yeah we're
so smart
sh sh sh sh need to get out of this it's
not Shaker
shaking all right whatever I guess it's
just going to flicker for a
bit I'm going to shake the crap out of
my freaking controller until it blows up
all right where am I dropping you
off how about right here it's good
enough for you
Ellie can you get up now
Ellie Ellie oh I see okay so they want
me to time I love being on this shut up
Ellie you just be glad I'm doing this
for you okay I get it they were trying
to be fed across the way to the other
side over here okay that makes much more
sense that means I need to go back and
take care of those clickers so I can
find out what they were guarding over
there all right I'll I'll get in in a
second wait is it over
here where am I taking you
guys can you get up
here oh no over there sorry sorry Ellie
I'll get it I'll get it don't worry
about me I'm just stupid
Joel okay there you go there you
go see that generator still got some
juice maybe here goes nothing
oh you can get it on the first try
really ain't that nice for
you all right all
right oh
no can't believe this actually worked
yeah don't jinx
this holy crap oh okay what is that
thing I've never seen that in a sewer
before
can I can I get up or do I have to go
the separate route with the clickers and
such really is this my I could have you
know you could have waited for me to get
back up and I could have gotten on that
thing and then uh we couldn't have to
deal with
this so
uh how about that you going to help me
out buddy you going to help me
out you going to you got to help me out
there we
go I I got to say I'm impressed with you
too oh thank you we're pros at this by
now all right I guess I'll just forget
what the clickers were guarding for
another day or forever and I'll get them
later I don't know what it was but
frankly I don't want to mess with them
just saying ooh level three tool oh yeah
more
supplements what's up with this what's
up with your
face are we really going in there no
other choice
what the hell is it like that area with
Fallout where the kids were guarding
that whole place that was weird that's a
trap it's a sound trap what it's a sort
of alarm I don't hear anything someone
used to live here mhm don't look like
that's the case anymore yeah sure
whatever house rules important please
read someone who thought they could keep
a place like this
safe that's weird okay there there
apparently a bunch of kids living here
at least that's what I can gather it's
kind of strange but guess it has to
happen some place what is that whoa saw
off shotgun stubby
shotgun shorty that's what it's called
probably uses the same ammo as a normal
shotgun but it's a pistol no it's
actually different it's different huh
that's so weird frankly I would rather
have a normal pistol and then just use
my shotgun separately but that's a whole
another story wonder what happened to
the people that lived here oh another
training manual what' I get what I
get hey Sam same
with oh look the plane did you see that
yeah let's keep down buddy okay a let
him have some fun okay I'm actually
almost full up on stuff I guess I might
as well how much okay I got full charges
on that thing so I'll just make a quick
melee weapon it should help with
clickers if I get near them
okay
supplements random stuff
here see let's see let's see let's
see bag of chips for oh that was
fertilizer for explosives okay I thought
it was a bag of potato chips you know
how they just are bursting with
flavor okay shut up all right moving
forward we got to find a Oh
e you hear
that infected sh
quiet hang on I got to swap out for good
old bow here what's with the bugs on the
wall that's so
weird where are they God I hope the
infected didn't get all the kids that
would be
horrible
hello
hello hey no pushing
Henry okay more
[Music]
rules whoa whoa whoa
wa whoa waa take that how about a melee
weapon to the
face I was expecting you to be a bit
more
bad give me a good shot give me bam oh
you there we go got
him okay that's a
clicker melee him screw him not dealing
with no clickers not messing around when
it comes to clickers I guess we know
what happened to these people see how
there was a clicker that had been gone
for a while yeah we keep moving forward
all we can do is hope there aren't any
more of them yep there are going to be
more don't worry about that ooh look
they had a whole water supply that's
kind of crazy they had a laundry room
and everything wow yeah this place got
overrun a long time ago but they were
living about as good as you can in this
place rain catcher I know what it is so
I don't need to read up on it
okay moving forward I guess stupid bugs
what are those
cockroaches what if there's a fungal
zombie that can affect cockroaches or
maybe they're still just totally immune
shable nope just normal
door what do we got more kids stuff more
stuff lying around another
note cornered note should be
sad we're trapped I think everyone else
is dead some of the little ones are with
me I got infected pounding at the door I
don't know how long we'll hold out if
ish and the others are alive maybe they
can reach us they have to reach us if it
comes down to it I'll make it
quick yep it was sad
yeah this is not happy fun times around
here okay don't need that wait what was
that that's a freaking machete sweet
does that machete have three instakill
charges oh yes it does oh yeah freaking
love it there's going to be clicker Bane
right
here see this is why I just wanted a
giant ass knife or a big sword you heard
me sword it's got the W you pronounce
the W in
Sword okay what do we got here more
supplies I'm being pretty good but hey
you think that leads Out full up
uncraftable so it's too high for what
would happen if I upgraded my m this
machete there I have no idea but I'm not
going to waste I guess it wouldn't be a
waste he let's find out I'm curious I'm
really am curious of what would happen
what did it do what did it do oo it gave
it five charges I put I put knives on my
on my sword it's so ridiculous whoa get
back sh oh
crap oh
crap yeah I'm cool that was me I must
have triggered some kind of safety gate
or something okay Henry see if we can
lift
this
so this is
awkward yeah I know it's like time what
hey this thing isn't budging man just go
get out of here Sam you stay close to
him Henry we got to move you
keep him safe go weird reversal going on
here
that's a lot of clickers I wouldn't want
to deal with those so I hope Henry is up
to the task oh no this is what happened
before I hope nothing bad's going to
happen I really don't I actually kind of
like
Henry come on kid see if we can find a
way out of here yeah all right I'm
getting a lot of parts I would love to
be able to upgrade my stuff I've got
literally tons and tons of Parts here it
won't tell me whoa waa waa whoa no you
don't oh melee melee come on melee there
we we go that's it that's a
stuff okay not going to deal with any of
you bull honky piece of you
just oh crap oh crap I'm going to melee
the piss out of
you thank you going to get you going to
get you wow there's one no oh no I was
going to get it that was that
was Bull this is all bull I hate
clickers I hate clickers I got good at
fighting humans not clickers I reload
damn it
wasting time just oh I got tons of
supplies here oh I got so much parts I
would love a bench yeah I know just let
him at me I'll take care of him hello
clicker head shot another
one go oh come on die already you
you this is my life this is my life this
is the story of my life right here this
is how it all go goes from now on I was
able to get head shot on human enemies
but these guys are just sons of
and they're never ever ever you know
what I'm actually going to switch to the
shorty i'm going to switch to the shorty
you guys are going to get it now going
to get it now going to learn today
you're going to learn today you're going
to learn today oh come on come on what
you got what you
got what what what oh is that your
friend he's suffering from a bad cat of
the
Dead
sorry kid did you get in the way of my
shotgun blast hope you didn't get hurt I
like this Shorty just cuz it's another
shotgun could always use another
shotgun what's that what's that what's
that out there oh your friends over here
they don't look go good they're a little
Dead behind the ears you want to maybe
take a look at them
huh got a brick with your name on it
I bet I bet Sam is going to jump
on their backs and stab them to nope not
today you chop your freaking head
off all come on come on who else
wants some oh what oh what what was that
what was that what's that I hear you wow
that's a lot of them holy
crap oh my God they're all just hiding
around okay there were more than I
thought but I can take you guys come on
bring it bring it who's next Who's Next
oh that's sad okay who's next you
next what you doing you jerks fing
jackasses come on I hear you someone
come at
me B
me one down a lot more to go come on
come on come
on who's next who's next I just got to
go out there until they come after
me okay come on yeah yeah yeah what what
you want yeah you better
run yeah yeah is it time it's go time
it's go time
boom that's what I thought more shorty
ammo thank you very much what what are
you a clicker you clicker you
clicker one man one gun one boy two men
all day every
day sorry I get a little I get a little
into this I'm getting a little too
excited about this okay there's still
one behind that pillar I know he's there
he's going to jump oh oh wa whoa waa
trying to sneak up on me right oh no I
knew you were going to get to jump on me
but not today okay what oh what oh what
what your friends all failed yeah they
did
oh how many are left a lot whoa It's
time it's go
time shorty
ammo I like this Shorty I like it a lot
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh is it is time is
it time oh you running away run away
running away little guys okay I see four
left they're all running in circles
let's see what you got what you got H
just wandering whoa what the oh
okay come on come on come on come on
come on let's do
this I missed there didn't miss that
time okay there's got to be like two or
three left two or three left yep thought
so damn it okay okay got one shorty
shell left who wants it whoa oh sorry
Sam I thought you were a zombie thought
you were a little old zomb on there okay
I think this is the last
one right around that corner no whoa
whoa whoa no no no no a damn it I
that up just suck that
down okay any left you did I did it
didn't I we're going to keep going you
good yeah all righty
then more
supplements ready to go okay I'm fully
out of shorty ammo so it's time to swap
out for that stick with the revolver for
now I'll use my regular shotgun for
everything else man I really like that
shorty shorty watching
shorties all
right woo that was that was a lot of zom
zoms but we're okay more shorty ammo I
like it but there were a lot of them
here people I mean looks like it poor
guys they all got turned into zom zoms
only takes one I
guess man wow there were a lot of people
in here that really sucks they had
showers and
bathrooms man this was a place to live I
mean it was still the sewers but they
turned it into a home
really sucks okay I got to heal up
actually it's very important stay
hydrated stay healed okay just make sure
my recording equipment doesn't crap out
on
me I mean I'm I'm actually doing really
well I think as far as uh keeping
Collectibles and my health up because
I'm actually kind of maxing out on
supplies and items okay we're going to
do the Boost this place go ahead it's
like a classroom yeah why couldn't they
keep it safe why couldn't they keep the
rest of the world safe
man n of people watching out someone got
careless one zombie got in panic million
reasons thank you there go almost hit me
in the head but okay whatever Sam you're
no Ellie you'll never be Ellie fing fing
ell come
on all
right Joel that's them Sam oh thank God
okie dokie we got to keep running
doorway over there smack him okay we're
running all right run run run run run
run many of them I could have fought him
but I
didn't there were like three what do you
mean too many of them get away from the
door maybe we push it together all right
whatever you say
man St up he just cwed through he
what Sam what the hell are you doing
getting us out of here being smart about
things there we go Sam out of boy out of
boy Sam all right don't need that still
got some charges on my machete I can
probably upgrade my machete if I really
wanted
to probably no time to upgrade now so
can't think about that
now all
right come on flashlight don't die on me
now got places to go things to do people
to be they look for supplies real
quickly real quickly scatter around SC
around SC around SC around what do we
got here lots of stuff shotgun ammo like
it can of beans bombs Molotov here give
me a boost maybe maybe I need to trap
stuff behind me I don't
know Ellie be careful open it from the
other side yeah that's what she's doing
come on Sam you're not staying in here
what about you I'll be fine come on yeah
we're the fighters we can do this I'm
going to I'm going to just lay some
traps out here just because I like the
idea of being a little get ready
preemptively
safe boom got one right off the bat whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa is that a clicker
blow up the clicker please didn't blow
up
come here come here clicker
suck on
that get the off of me I'm trying I'm
trying I'm
trying back I probably didn't need to do
that okay all right doing okay do doing
okay doing
okay
boom
clicker oh come on reloading freaking
reloads good get back out of the way
they're freaking clickers okay let's go
let's go all right we got it
really wow all right
then fresh air yeah
ha look at
this oh are you kidding me oh
thanks for the warning on the other side
guys so where's this
Tower we're close we are you sure about
that let's go hope so okay that was
surprising at least I used my bombs
effectively now I can actually make some
oh crap I don't have blades that's right
how you doing little man all right
that's fine fine I didn't pick up that
last bombb in there because I thought I
had
time yeah not one of
our without a scratch too good job okay
there's supplies in there I'm getting a
lot of parts I want to upgrade my gear
but I haven't found a workbench in a
while just trying to keep up to date I
know you guys are criticizing every
every move I'm make in this game but I
will try to persevere in a more
professional
fashion yep what I tell you that's just
as far as the
this this is ridiculous always a
landmark that we're going for about you
how you holding up business as usual
right when I was with Henry I took out a
couple of infected by
myself he'd be proud
yeah yeah
yeah I'm so proud of you
Ellie okay knives yes intense back there
huh oh
yeah
oh
I A friend of mine marleene asked
me long well
yeah yeah that's right I didn't
respond cuz I'm a badass no one bosses
Joel round no one puts Joel in the
corner no one puts baby Joel in the
corner okay whatever searching this
whole house I don't know how many of
these houses I'll search fully but
hopefully I can find some things like
some more parts I would love to find a
workbench that would be
amazing that would be exactly what I
would want more knives is okay wait was
that a knife or or what I wonder why I
can't carry more than seven rifle rounds
that seems like a gross oversight all
right let's go
man I checked everything in that house
right I think top to bottom I'm pretty
sure I got
everything
oh you I really do love the music in
this game cuz it's very fitting with the
theme it sounds like throughout the
whole game the music has sounded very
lonely and very sorrowful which is kind
of what the game is all about doggies
you're going to want to stay away from
those it's not like it is in the zone
these are wild yeah what is this oh this
is an ice cream truck ice cream truck
yeah and told me about these they'd sell
ice cream out of the truck what no way
Joel yeah it's true that's true this
thing drive around and play real loud
creepy music and kids would come running
out to buy ice cream you're totally
with
serious man you lived in a strange time
I guess when you put it that way told
you so it is kind of
weird this weird truck comes out of
nowhere starts playing music all the
kids run come running that seems like a
strange operation going on there more
knives I like it I love
it all right now see here let me check
upstairs real quick and then we'll get
out of
here hope I don't have to shoot those
dogs that would not be nice okay was
that car I just heard in here or out
there father's
not no whoops whoa whoa whoa damn
it Father's no all right you do the
adult while I'm gone take care of your
brother he's looking to you for
protection now I won't be gone for more
than a few days to gather food and
supplies if for some reason I haven't
returned after a week take your brother
and head to the picksburgh quarantine
Zone that's a bad idea don't open the
door to anyone but me save your bullets
if you have to leave stay low and move
quickly use your size to your advantage
I'll see you soon dad oh man so much
sadness in this game just everywhere you
go it's just non-stop
sadness
okay oh man it's a shame too I mean just
think about it how many stories are out
there that what happened in this place
like just how many sad sad stories how
many families got broken up how many
lives got destroyed and people lost this
is why I don't want a zombie apocalypse
some people say they do this is why I
don't cuz it would just be horrible and
probably every one of you guys would be
like no I'd be one of the survivors
you'd be infected on day one and I would
be too we'd all be infected no one none
of us would be survivors you might be
going oh no I'm on no you you door bash
didn't if the zombies don't get you then
the people would that's why run away
guys it's for the best doggies all right
let's move
forward see is there something up there
n okay I guess that's the way we need to
go fireflies were here yeah by the looks
of it how are we going to find them I
know a guy a brother actually M he was a
firefly last I heard he was in Wyoming
we get there we find him we find the
fireflies Wyoming's a long way out
man
Oho so where are we going I can't tell
what direction we're going don't know
what that flash of light was either all
right where are we going man what are we
doing
here this whole place is collapsed where
are we going point something out to me
cuz I'm not seeing
it maybe oh maybe in the other side of
that house that I was in I could
probably find another way around or this
is a different house
actually lots of supplies but I'm almost
maxed out on everything besides you know
gears and maybe another tool I could
find I keep call them gears I know
they're just like nuts and bolts or
something let me check upstairs I know
you guys would kill me if I wasn't being
thorough
so flashlight going
out all right here's another
note another note see what we
got see oh one Open Door that's all it
took one of us forgot to close a door
and a hoard of these monsters entered
our camp we shut them in there and wrote
a warning on the outside oh really yeah
see that's how it happens Su and a
couple other kids were with me as far as
I know we're the only survivors I had to
hold Susan so she wouldn't run in back
in there go back for the bodies it's
just too dangerous she lost her children
and I have no clue what to say to her
every part of my being just wants to
give up it'd be so easy to surrender to
this world I can't do that though I have
too much faith in humanity I've seen
that we're still capable of good we can
make it I have to stay strong for her
ish this is Ish again man ish I don't
know where I saw ish before but I think
I did another Comon found another one of
them Comics oh cool cool all right now
she finally seems grateful
gosh o a safe can I open that need
combination oh I have a combination for
a different thing but not this I never
did find the safe on that truck damn
it what the hell
it was probably one of the Survivor
notes from like downstairs or something
matchbook is there some on the matchbook
821 36 oh
yeah yeah wait hang on where did it go
where did it go where' the matchbook go
there it is okay oh yeah read it 821 36
flip it around oh
yeah I'm so excited I can't believe I
can't believe it was right here
sweet arrows I'm all excited man I'm
jazzed up I'm jazzed up man can't deny
my excitement okay here we go oh yeah
I'm so
excited oh yeah oh that was it oh 50
Parts okay I'll take that hell yeah for
going up one stairs see this is why you
guys would have killed me if I had
overlooked
that DS hey
Sam come on Sam careful got to go time
to
go let's go Sam got to get a move
on ooh it is actually bright and
sunshiny but this looks like a horrible
place to be just
saying yep I knew
it
sniper did you see where it came from
yeah I saw down the street I see it I'm
going to take him out y'all stay here no
before you start I need you guys to keep
him busy okay I'm going to go around and
see if I can't get the angle on him okay
hey be careful it's me we're talking
about it's Joel It's Joel all right here
we
go that was too close keep him busy do
something nothing you're not going to do
nothing okay okay that was a
shot
wo I can't take him out there's no way
I'd be able to line up the shot right
away okay shoot
man did you want
to duck my head completely
out there we go whoa whoa where'd you
come from nope a damn it see again
that's not fair machete you oh that
was the last of my machete fudge all
right hang on I got to
see uh yeah this is what I want to do
get some insta kills on me humans again
I can deal with humans this just those
damn clickers that I don't like let's
see if I can get a vantage point maybe
anti- snipe this guy counter sniper
whatever you want to call it those
knives sweet tree blocking my way
okay got to find a different
place all right yeah hide in that house
see if that helps
really okay where do you think you're
going
I'm going out the back I mean I probably
shouldn't have told you that but that's
what I was doing you
asked okay can I get a shot from here I
need
to swap this out for my sniper see if I
can't damn it I can't get a clear shot I
don't even see his
head I was probably close but not close
enough okay where am I going that car
here we
go sting don't it you missed me doesn't
sting at
all missed me
dick okay got to go around this
fence am I close enough now no way I can
get in that house there but I got to
move why aren't they doing anything to
distract this guy what does that say SOS
for the win okay that was a shot Fu no
you don't who you missed me owie that
hurt okay that one actually stung a
bit ordinarily in real life a single
sniper rifle would take you down and
keep you down but oh come on I don't
have a shot from this place no you do
not shut up
okay am I full on both of those
apparently I am all right
that was this was a fruitless Endeavor
unless there's a back door yes okay cool
awesome whoa what the hell that was
well no you don't no come on
let me get the let me hit him yeah there
we go jeez
whoa here you go you're getting
them okay who's
there not working out whoa where'd you
go f there killed you dead get down here
where is this other guy he's in that
house or where is he okay I'm going to
Brick one of you
guys got nowhere to go oh yeah I do just
trust me on that
one I really wish I could pull people
down get out cuz that would be
amazing yeah come
on a son of a
there we go took him out see if I
can't get in this house here okay
there's that guy
yeah sneaky that's a word for
it you see how I picked my head right
above that thing you didn't see that you
didn't see that at all good good keep it
that way
okay what can I do to take this guy out
I don't have any I've been seeing a lot
fewer bricks and Bottles than I have in
the past I don't know why that is but
apparently I'm full on shorty
ammo probably just oh oh come on
that's
bull damn it that was that was total
bull I wasn't paying attention at all
okay never mind ignore that happened I
was doing good up until that
point okay anyway
way I think it's just the one guy left
up in the sniper Roost now wasn't there
a way to get in this house I thought I
saw maybe I climb up on this and get in
here can't Smash in the window there we
go that's what I'm talking
about all your friends are dead why do
you want to
play whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
what the these guys getting to jump on
me come here I'm going strangle that
piss out of you okay that means it was
the last guy out in the
open and that means that I can get a
good shot on these guys or this guy
whatever you want to call it
maybe can I hit him yeah I think I can
hit him from here well whether or not I
can hit him is
totally a different question see hang on
OWI we what the hell okay I can't hit
him that's bull I got to go
around I'm not handling this well sorry
guys I know I'm
not okay jump out here stay
down
okay seriously my friends were supposed
to keep you busy they did not do any of
that oh crap oh crap oh
crap bust out the good old shotgun after
this
okay I'm in the house
see how good you are
now it'll be real
sorry okay this there isn't a way in
through here that
sucks I need to make another
medkit two
actually I'm going to get this don't
worry about this I'm all over
it over here shut down
there okay what are we looking
at okay there's one immediately over
there trying to cycle around the house
is he coming inside though that's all I
care about okay he's not coming in whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa that's what I thought Coming For
You see if you can snipe me from
well sniping me from Point Blank Range
might actually be pretty easy so don't
do that and let's just settle this
amicably whoa who's that where below me
okay below
me
oh you going to get
it oh you going to get
it
[Applause]
that's what I'm talking
about how about now
how about now who's a sniper now uh-oh
that's not
good all right oh my God you you're
making me snipe oh my God oh my God oh
my God boom head shot come on come on
oh damn it damn it was
close
boom boom okay I don't got to get head
shot which is awfully nice for
me cuz with my skill level it would not
Happened One boom head
shot boom heart shot see what do we got
boom almost head
shot where are you at where you at there
you are got you doing good doing good
only missed once doing pretty good
where's the last one guys I almost shot
Ellie right in the head jeez where's the
last one there you
go come on got get in the arm and that
got you down anyway good enough good
enough good enough where you shooting at
where are they from where they coming
from there we are come on come on come
on
boom Oh I saw that can't hide from me
got you wo that guy went flying H boom
so I see
you
boom where's he going where I saw
another one there he
is Boom
car how many of them are there
jeez oh
no you got to be joking me oh that is
bull why are they all the way how you
here get away from us huh we're back
but why why are you back
why bother it seems like a waste of
effort Oh Come come on I hit that
one got you right in the
come
on head
shot can't hide there bad place to hide
where' you go where'd you go where'd you
go got
you I saw that there you
go see
you got you so dark in those Shadows I
can barely see them is that one that's
not one is it whoa whoa something
happened
there a I knew something
happened is
that damn that thing is freaking
Invincible oh man I got to get that guy
he pops out for like a quarter of a oh
come on come on
Joel
oh come on
no Jesus you got to be joking me I was
God I missed
there please don't make me do the whole
thing again oh I could zoom a second
time are you joking me really I could
have done
that damn
it come on come on come on where you at
where you
at where you at where you at bring it up
on
up there we go yeah that's more like it
hell yeah I didn't know I could zoom in
again
that wasn't yes let's just pretend
I got that on the first try okay yeah
I'm
okay thanks Joel you're welcome Ellie
you're the best look at
this okay all right we did
it just keeping an eye out should
move all right just making sure
Sam oh crap oh crap oh crap come on no
Henry come on I got this
oh no oh no Sam are you okay oh no
yeah oh no you sure I said I'm fine come
on come on oh crap let's move I knew
there was a reason for me being still up
here hurry up hurry
up
damn it come on got to hit my
targets where are they where are they
all got you
one down one
down clicker going
down got another one no no no no oh holy
crap Jesus it's s that freaking those
freaking humans just LED all those
things in here why why bother we weren't
that big of a deal it was not that
important to come get us oh you're okay
what's doing here anybody hurt uh- no
we're good I think it's time we quit
this place come on let's go let him in
burn the place down is what I'd
do I would burn that house to the
ground oh Sam got bitten shut the hell
up that serious oh no it's Tommy's
birthday and that's all he wanted to do
is
just rent two Harley and drive cross
country oh
man I could die happy if I could just
ride one around the
block what was it
like it was good it was real good good
can you believe this guy come on man
give me details describe it you know
what you two deserve a little privacy no
no Ellie Ellie this isn't just any
regular motorcycle okay you get on that
bad boy you feel that engine nothing
like it oh yeah how would you know seen
it in my
[Music]
dream okay I like this guy but I still
have a really bad feeling oh
no I don't think anyone from my group is
GNA show
up
yeah worst part about it all explaining
it to
Sam well it's safe to say those two have
officially
bonded what are you
doing taking stock of all the food we
found today I
see and how are we doing doing on canned
peaches did Henry send
you
no why would Henry send me to make sure
I'm not up
somehow I'd say we all did pretty good
back there especially
you is everything all
right everything's fine
okay
well have a good
night how is it that you're never
scared maybe he's not says that I'm
not what are you scared
of let's
see scorpions are pretty creepy
uh being by
myself I'm scared of ending up
alone what about
you those things out
there what if the people are still
inside what if they're trapped in there
without any control of their
body
scared of that happening to
me okay first of all we're Team now okay
we're going to help each other out and
second they might still look like people
but that person is not in there
anymore Henry says that they've moved on
that they're with their families like in
heaven do you think that's
true
I go back and
forth I mean I'd like to believe
it but you
don't I guess
not yeah me
neither oh all the serious
talk I almost
forgot there if he doesn't doesn't know
about it you can't take it
away all right I'm
pooped I'll see you
tomorrow I really hope he wasn't
bitten
shaser oh no oh no oh
no God damn it I knew it hell
damn
it man something else about Ellie she
used such a strange assortment of
phrases like I'm pooped to something
that I haven't heard in a long time
voila I'll let him sleep in for once oh
god well if you want him to join us you
can go wake his ass up this is not good
okay oh no oh no oh no Sam
Sam what the
hell he's
turning whoa that's my
brother screw
[Music]
it
you all
right oh my God
see oh no
Sam Henry Henry stay there
Henry what have you done I'm going to
get that gun from you okay oh okay okay
easy is this your fault this is nobody's
fault Henry it's all your fault
Henry Henry
no oh my
[Music]
God
oh
man
oh oh
man oh that's I knew something bad was
going to happen I knew it I knew
something bad was going to
happen
ah
It's amazing how quickly it went
from happy that they had supplies and
food and stuff to
that they weren't kidding but that came
on
quick
is the end of every season change
kind of Jackson County never mind means
we're close to Jackson City right
shouldn't be more than a few miles you
ready to see dear old brother I'm just
ready to get there you nervous I don't
know what I'm
feeling he changed his shirt she changed
your jacket I guess it's getting into
fall
so you can't just do that to
meu can't just do that to me instantly
do that and then suddenly change as if
nothing happened that's not good all
right whatever we're fine moving
on oh all right it's a new place I need
a workbench oh
you just follow the river it'll
lead us straight to tomy's so are we
going to go down I'm not dropping down
there I guess maybe I am no I'm not okay
so where are we going to go oh this way
okay all right then I got no jokes to
crack guys seriously I don't but
um let's just stop it here for
now man this game is very serious
and oh
man you know I can imagine this this
game would be fun if you could see like
like a professional gamer playing this
silently I kind of feel like this game
is spoiled with commentary this would be
amazing to just see um someone play
through this totally silent doing no
commentary but plays through it
perfectly like completely perfectly like
no never getting shot at never getting
hit um if he does get shot like you know
very rarely uh dealing with things
professionally never dying I would love
to see that just to see like all that
actually happen but anyway I'm all done
for this one so thank you all so much
for watching Click The annotation for
more videos that I've done and as always
I will see you in the next video
bye-bye
go
another one am I just going to be
wandering
around I thought I don't know how I got
into
[Music]
here that this game definitely got the
average obviously play this
[Music]
game I